I wanted to start with something that
I'm fascinated by which is you two are
some of the rare people I get to talk to
you that have worked extensively on the
West End and on Broadway and I'm curious
is there a difference in the audiences
between the West End and Broadway less
now used to be a big difference I find
there changing for example standing
ovations the Brits never used to get on
their feet and cheer and now they all do
and every show I go to everyone jumps to
their feet whereas American audiences
are very very and lovely for us Brits it
used to be coming to America and the
sort of positivity and the downside of
the ìiî of the American audience is that
they laugh it's very good that they
laugh when things are funny but often
they laugh as a sort of nervous reaction
they don't sometimes quite get the
subtlety between what is actually
serious
and what is meant to be funny so that
there's a gut reaction of laughter every
time and sometimes I I would find that a
bit distracting or whatever in Menard
cities like New York and London and long
runs of plays and when I started the
theater you would count yourself lucky
to be in a play for a year it doesn't
happen these days they're much much
shorter runs the audience would change
and to begin with you would get a local
audience you would get people who lived
in London and as they made the show
success people and from a town tourists
would visit some of whom didn't stop
spam don't speak English very well and
they don't necessarily make good
audiences now an extreme example of this
was when we were on Broadway with dance
of death but August Strindberg heavy
duty stuff and just before we opened
September the 11th happened and suddenly
a Manhattan
to prison you couldn't move in or out of
the island and so the shows that belong
for years like producers for which you
could not normally get a ticket where
empty because the tourists weren't yeah
yeah and they were to take their seats
but the local audience who were trapped
on to Manhattan came to see the nearest
show in town which was out so at the
height of September 11th the biggest
success on Broadway was played by August
Strindberg called dance of dance what's
fascinating that I also learned was that
you guys have worked together on
Broadway but you've never made a movie
together
no until this what was it like because
I'm in imagine every actor has a little
bit of a different process what was it
like working together making a movie
together
I think we'd more in common than we have
separate yes I mean the film is it's
such a such a different animal obviously
from the theater you know in the theater
you you are the editor of your of the
performance you you know when to go fast
when to go slow when to you know you
edit your performance in a way to the to
the live audience film obviously so
different you are you know even if we're
playing here I would hardly be playing
to you I'd be playing in a way to the
camera that might be here somewhere
so it's just a very different experience
and and really what you want more than
anything on film is for people I guess
to give it the same level of passion and
and seriousness and concentration and
discipline that you are bringing
yourself to it and and if you get that
then it's great and and you know all the
[ __ ] are working and we respect each
other and it's not just learning to
respect each other in the job like if
you meet you some of the first time I
know who Helen Mirren is she's having
been a big part of my life as a some
nights watching acting on screen and on
stage so nothing but a thrill to meet
her and a horse
gonna relieve that she's as good to work
with this year's to watch I mean the cut
from the same cloth ready um I first of
all you guys are great in this movie and
I thought it was one of the things I
really dug about what Bill did is that
it keeps you guessing till the very end
yeah can you sort of talk about doesn't
lie to you that's also true the story
does not reach you right can you sort of
talk about how it will keep you guessing
to the very end and also maybe what drew
you to the script for me the
unexpectedness of the script do that and
also that these two protagonists are
absolute protagonists I can't think of
another film where you have two people
of this sort of age and experience and
all the rest of it absolutely right in
the center of the movie as the two
protagonists its original and great
great fun because each scene is set up
you think you know what's going to
happen you know what she wants and you
know what he wants and which and those
get kept out on top and it's usually the
other person
so oh I think that would be my ration if
I saw oh well it was about turning this
year oh is it more important than that
and then a bit of entertainment up to
you really
there are big events behind their story
which which inform it so it can be a
very grown-up experience seeing this
film but I think at heart at the
beginning at least and probably and it's
a thriller and we're really hoping that
the audience don't tell their friends
what's what it's all about
it's like Hitchcock at the end of psycho
was saying do not tell you know your
your friends the end of this film and he
was quite right because of course if you
knew the to watch it you know first time
I saw Hamlet I
didn't know what happened in the end can
you imagine watching Hamlet on that
level as an absolute thriller Hamlet is
a thriller
I had except when I was playing Hamlet
we were in Aberdeen which is in Scotland
hunter and there was a little girl at
the disco and she was shaking hasn't
known what was going to her didn't know
about it taught me everything about
doing Shakespeare do it as if it's being
watched for the fund everything
including the good liar absolutely yes
I have to go congratulations on the
movie yeah other interviews to do but
seriously it's a pleasure to talk to you